kendall jenner and devin booker bring
pda to the nba here's the model and
basketball star kissing courtside at the
phoenix suns vs los angeles lakers game
over the weekend kendall was cheering on
her boyfriend with pals justin and
hailey bieber by her side but it was
after the suns beat the lakers that
devin surprised fans by rushing to his
girlfriend and giving her a hug and a
kiss and that rare moment of pda between
the pair has kendall's sister khloe
kardashian's stamp of approval the good
american founder showed her support by
sharing the same photo of the love birds
on her instagram story i think
having so many people
like love you is such a blessing the
private couple has been getting more
public with their romance after more
than a year of dating back in june
kendall confirmed that devin is her
boyfriend on the reunion special for
keeping up with the kardashians and
explain why she's chosen to keep her
love life private no offense to my older
sisters at all but i think that kylie
and i specifically have you know had the
opportunity to watch my older sisters
you know go through marriages and
and relationships and breakups and all
these things and and do them i have to
be there for you no do them pretty
publicly and like again no offense to
you guys at all but i think just it was
personal preference
from like a really young age that i
didn't really want to like
yeah i think it makes my life a lot
easier and our relationship a lot
better to be completely honest i just
feel like it's a private matter it's not
really for anybody else to to judge or
know privacy has been important for
kendall for a while check out what she
told et back in 2015.
it's not always easy
but i don't know i just kind of i like
to keep my private life pretty private
so
um i try my best but at the same time i
don't i don't like to let
being seen out in public with someone
like affect my everyday life since
confirming the news of their
relationship kendall and devon have
shared cute moments together on
instagram like this photo of the couple
snuggling up and enjoying their italian
getaway on the amalfi coast last summer
a source previously told et that devin
is sweet smart fun and totally not a
player he is very respectful and was
raised with very good values kendall
finds that to be a very attractive
quality plus our source says the
couple's busy schedules are not an issue
when it comes to finding time for one
another the source adds quote they're
not putting any sort of pressure on
things for the future they realize
they're both still young and have big
futures ahead of them right now they're
just enjoying their time together and
taking things as they come
[Music]